cher journal j'ai gardé mes neveux ce
week-end deux jours ressenti quatre
semaines je pense qu'on devrait donner
des noms d'ouragan aux enfants quand mon
frère m'a dit qu'ils étaient en pleine
forme j'ai d'abord pensé à une forme
connue j'ai suivi un parcours scolaire
complet je pensais connaître à peu près
toutes les formes de quelle prétention
je crois que si je devais tirer une
leçon de cet événement ce serait
l'humilité car vraiment je n'ai rien vu
venir
il y avait pourtant quelques signes
avant coureurs comme la pression qui a
chuté brutalement ou des vagues d'une
hauteur sans précédent je ne pensais pas
vivre dans une région à risque mais dès
qu'ils ont pointé le bout de leur nez
de violentes bourrasques ont tout
détruit sur leur passage
à un moment j'ai cru voir l'oeil du
cyclone se fermer le silence sans poser
mais l'accalmie a été de très courte
durée
et alors même que j'allais demander du
renfort la force centrifuge est devenu
totalement incontrôlable nous sommes en
train aux rouges voire violette j'ai
verrouillé les portes et les fenêtres
placés en hauteur les quelques documents
importants qui n'avaient pas encore été
détruits
n'ayant pas de baume au coeur à
disposition j'ai réussi à trouver un
abri sécurisé
muni d'un stock de piles aa évidemment
c'était des aaa dont j'avais besoin
ou l'inversé plus tôt
puis plus rien alors je n'étais pas
devenue sourde
c'était tout simplement le bruit du
calme qui était revenu je me demande
comment de si petites choses peuvent
faire de si grands dégâts et bizarrement
je crois que j'ai déjà hâte d'être à la
prochaine tornade
enfin je vais quand même prendre un
petit peu de vacances deux jours quoi ou
quatre semaines
[Musique]